This video is brought to you by skill
share the first 500 people to sign up
with the link in the description.
We'll get a two month free trial.
Hey,
wise crack jared here.
As you grow older,
you come to learn some hard truths.
Santa isn't real.
Serial makes you fat.
Space Jam is a bad movie.
It's a natural and inevitable course,
but that's why I'm here to bury your
childhood completely.
That's right.
Your childhoods last happy gasps of
excitement will be drowned out by the
plump,
plump up dirt,
slowly encasing it.
So get ready to become a hardened
alcoholic with three mortgages and an
angry ex wife because I'm here to tell
you that the lion king is actually
cinemas.
Cutest advocacy of totalitarian ethics.
Welcome this wise crack condition on the
lion king and as always spoilers ahead
but seriously wasn't seen as the movie.
While the lion king is one of the most
beloved films of the Disney Cannon,
the Animal Kingdoms political landscape
also happens to be eerily similar to
some of the worst ideologies of not only
the 20th century,
but arguably of all time.
The Lion King tells the story of Simba a
young lion or Dane to succeed his father
move Fossa as king of the pride lands.
Mufasa teaches his young son all about
proper rulership and the delicate
balance of nature that a king must
uphold.
However,
Mufasa as brothers scar covets the
throne gets moved,
Fossa killed and convinces the young
Simba that it's all his fault before
claiming the throne for himself.
Some lives out his shame with some
carefree hippies before returning to the
pride land to reclaim his rightful
throne.
Also,
it's based on hamlet.
If the lion king,
we're just the story of a king,
his prints and a jealous brother.
There wouldn't be much to say,
but it isn't just that.
In fact,
the film posits two principles which
have been justifying the world's worst,
desperate since before despots even
existed.
The first is seemingly the most
wholesome at the beautiful balance of
nature is the basis for politics or as
the film memorably calls it.
The film's famous opening number
displays the majestic nature of the
African Savanna and the glorious natural
order of things we Fossa establishes
that pride rock is run on basic natural
tenants.
Everything the light touches is all
a king's time.
As ruler rises and falls like the sun
hell,
the sky opens up and shines a halo over
move fosters newborn son.
The heavens literally marking the lions
as the rightful natural rulers.
The imagery couldn't be any clearer if
they tacked on a Kyron stating obey,
move Fossa.
And while you may wonder what it means
for a society that is ruled by someone
like a lion who eats his subjects,
don't worry.
The circle of life is beautiful.
Yes,
but let me explain.
When we die,
our bodies become the grass and the
antelope eat the grass.
And so we owe connected in the great
circle of life,
even though to be more scientifically
accurate,
it's more likely that for the antelope,
at least they're fully digested.
Brothers and sisters will be excreted by
the likes of Simba to fertilize the
grass,
which they'll eat.
So it's like cannibalism with extra
steps.
And while it seems like a message that
even an environmentalist could get on
board with,
this is where it gets dark.
All the monkeys,
elephants and giraffes seem to happily
accept their place in society,
hailing the birth of a creature that may
very well eat them one day even move is
faithful servant quickly gets over the
fact that he's assaulted and humiliated
as prey because well,
he is praying,
but not everyone is happy with their lot
in life.
The hyenas are at the bottom of the food
chain,
presumably because they're scavengers.
You're looking at you guys,
and when we're dangling at the bottom of
the food chain,
it's clear that hyenas aren't welcome in
pride rock.
So they'd been relegated to starve in an
elephant graveyard.
So that's principle one,
that there is a natural order to things
that must be adhered to.
Those who are at the bottom of the food
chain must accept their place for the
greater good.
This whole vision of rulership as
maintaining harmony is not new.
It was advocated by Plato,
but according to philosopher Karl
Popper,
also known as k pop,
it's pretty much responsible for
everything.
Terrible.
That's happened in western history
sense.
Popper calls this general framework,
whole Islam,
the idea that the whole of a society is
more important than the individual and
what's good for society is usually
defined by some in controvertible law,
whether it be natural order,
racial purity,
or the laws of history.
Popper explains that for Plato to keep
one's place is a virtue and popper goes
on to explain that in this view of the
world and individual's goal is to be a
perfectly crafted cog in the great
clockwork of societal.
Different cogs will have different
roles,
but the virtue of keeping one's place
will be common to all of them and it
will the same time be the virtue of the
hole.
That of being properly fitted together,
of being in harmony to this universal
principle,
Plato gives the name,
justice,
justice.
This theory of justice popper argues is
totalitarian morality.
In a nutshell if the individual is
simply a cog than ethics is nothing but
how to make them fit there and to get
all historical popper pointed out that
Plato,
a dennison of Athens seem to have a
boner for Sparta,
which when you think about it is a cruel
eugenics driven military dictatorship
and for popper,
Plato's politics have been ruining the
world ever since.
Inspiring everyone from petty tyrants to
big,
bad totalitarian nightmares to break
this harmony for plato would be chaos or
more specifically democracy.
No,
seriously,
Plato's whole view of democracy was that
it gives the right to rule to those who
have no business in doing so,
the poor,
the landless and the stupid sound like
anyone we'll call this scary principle
1.5
because it fits into the larger holism
piece.
Democracy for Plato is a sort of catch
22 where sure all the people are equal
and free to do whatever they like,
but because most people are self
interested,
dicks society will quickly collapse as
everyone pursues their own shortsighted
goals.
There's no food,
no water,
it's dinner time or we ain't got no
stinking entrees.
In a democracy.
The lower class grows bigger and more
emboldened.
They break the law with impunity,
run naked in the streets and then form
their own youtube channels or whatever
the equivalent was back then.
Now listen,
I'm not here to say that we should all
collectively worship at the altar of
democracy and freak out whenever there's
a well reasoned criticism of it.
It's certainly not an infallible system.
I like him.
He looks me in the eye.
I'm like
beer with him.
I'm voting for him,
but well,
there's a difference between reasonable
criticism and pro authoritarian
propaganda.
Scar in the hyenas aren't exactly out
for democracy,
but they are out for equal footing.
A new way in which lie on and Hyena come
together in our grapes,
been relegated to the pride lands
equivalent of New Jersey where they're
doomed to star.
They're being manipulated by scar.
Who wants to be king for his own ends?
And this mirrors the way as Plato
predicts democracy and never bubbly ends
in tyranny with demagogues making false
promises to the poor and hungry.
Hi,
why don't make hay strict quit on me.
Scar fully embodies plato's
quintessential tyrant per play.
Doh eight hybrids is the worst type of
man,
a man so consumed by his own lawless
desires that he will do anything to
achieve them even murder.
No.
Yeah.
When you have tyrants who have not
achieved internal harmony,
they go d harmonizing everything around
them.
When scar takes control of pride rock
for some inexplicable reason,
the rivers run dry and the bright lush
pride lands are reduced.
Weight bearing gray wasteland and scar
is supposed to be the smart one and he's
absolutely right.
If the pride lands are suffering,
it's because scar has usurped the
natural order of things.
And if you dare question your natural
lot in life,
well you must be a villain.
It's an argument that would be well
received in the halls of any monarchy or
a dictatorship.
And to bring abundance back to his
homeland symbols,
ghost ad reminds him to restore the
natural or
takes your place in the circle of the
rice
and like magic.
Once Simba sends the usurper scar to his
death,
rejuvenating rains fall on the pride
lands bringing abundance and prosperity.
Once again.
The second
more creepy principle.
The film is spouses.
Is One less associated with Plato and
more?
Well,
every sociopath ever might makes right.
This dismal view of society holds that
all morality isn't governed reason or
the exchange of ideas,
but brute force and weirdly the film
just seems to go right out there and
admit it as hot as brains go.
I got the lion's share,
but when it comes to blue to strengths,
I'm afraid I'm at the shallow end of the
gene who scars.
Intelligence is connected to his
deceitful illness,
whereas his brother strength is
connected to his nobleness.
This view is a favorite of not only Nazi
Germany but pretty much any country
trying to invade this out if their
weaker neighbors.
So what do you guys think?
Have we successfully ruined your
childhood or how have we gone straight
for the tin foil hats?
Let us know in the comments and thanks
for watching guys.
Peace.
Thanks for watching.
Wise crack.
You guys often ask us how we make our
videos and maybe you've noticed we've
been trying some different stuff lately.
It's been a blast experiment.
If you've been needing to try something
new with a project or learn a skill but
aren't sure how to jump in.
Checkout skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning
community where you can take classes in
pretty much everything and they're ready
to give you the push you need to take
the plunge into your dream project.
Skillshare has over 17,000
professional and easy to use classes in
design,
photography,
business,
and so much more.
Whether you're already a creator or
you're looking to become one,
you'll find likeminded people with steps
and advice on how to take your ideas to
the next level.
You can take classes on everything from
the basics of html or how to draw using
ink to how to put together a rock in
presentation.
Or if you're feeling inspired by the
lion king,
you could even take a class in basic
animation and create the next childhood
nostalgia icon.
So head over to s,
k l.
Dot.
S.
H.
Slash wise crack three to begin your two
month free trial and get learning.
So get out there and create all,
and if you want to keep up with what
we're creating,
don't forget to subscribe and ring that
bell.
Thanks for watching.
Catch on.
Next time.